[Music]
foreign
foreign
okay
this is a test of the audio system this
is a test
of the audio system
this is a test of the audio system
the press conference is due to begin
shortly but this is just a test
of the audio system i repeat this is
just a test
bit more sure
the date is tuesday february 23rd
2021 we are in the lomita station
fantastic anybody else need a test
everybody
thank
good
that's
is
[Music]
[Music]
piece of paper
okay
me
five minutes
oh man am i gonna be in your way
how much
today but we are going to do it because
we know there'll be a lot of questions
you know it's an active investigation
there's only so much that you share at
this point but so that you're aware
it will be the statement from the
sheriff and then
the chief the party and then we're gonna
go to spanish language remarks
[Music]
hey guys
i do you hear me
double now
i do i'm talking you guys might check
so
oh
um
foreign
hey guys
i hear them
they're coming out elizabeth
here i'll give that to my uh
good afternoon i'm joe mendoza captain
of the sheriff's information bureau
thank you for coming to this press
conference to discuss a traffic
collision
which occurred this morning involving
aldrich tiger woods
joining sheriff yanueva is lamina
station captain james powers
and other members of the executive
command staff
also joining us here today is ellie
county fire chief
darryl osby now i would like to
introduce the sheriff of los angeles
county
alex villanueva
thank you captain mendoza
today at 7 12 in the morning lomita
sheriff's station received a call of a
solo vehicle collision
in harbor or hawthorne boulevard north
of
palos verdes drive we arrived on scene
at 7 18
a.m and discovered the solar vehicle
collision
and the soul occupant was again tiger
woods
and deputies at the time they did not
see any evidence of impairment anything
that
uh of concern obviously the life-setting
measures that had to be taken
for the occupant of the vehicle and uh
chief cosby will speak to that
regard and it was a solo vehicle
unfortunately during the course of the
investigation of this there was another
traffic collision that happened with
people being looking loose and but that
definitely there was injuries associated
with that the
vehicle travels several hundred feet
from the center uh center divider
at the intersection and rested on the on
the
west side of the road in the brush
sustained major damage
vehicle you've seen all the images of
that and uh
with that our lamia sheriff's station
will be conducting the traffic
investigation
and they'll take them from days of
several weeks to get the whole thing
together once the
in the investigation is completed we
will provide a detailed uh
report it'll be available you know based
on public record act request
and we will not discuss any further
after that point
at this point i want to introduce chief
daryl osby ellie county fire department
good afternoon i'm fire chief daryl osby
of the los angeles county fire
department at approximately 7
22 this morning resources from los
angeles county
fire station 106 received a report of a
solo vehicle accident at the
intersection of hawthorne boulevard
and paul is very drive north in rolling
hills of state
upon arrival at the scene of the
incident of sheriff's on scene
uh resources and personnel from the los
angeles county fire department
observed a single rollover vehicle
incident with one person
trapped the person trapped uh
was extricated by the los angeles county
fire department personnel
earlier it was stated that the jaws of
life was utilized
to extricate the person trapped
it was later determined by our personnel
that a holiday tube
which is used for prying and the axe
was also used to pry the person free
from the vehicle
the patient was packaged at the incident
in stable condition with serious
injuries
and because of the fact that they needed
to be extricated
they were transported to harbor
ucla hospital because of the extrication
and harvard hospital is also a
promising as indicated earlier there's
also a second vehicle accident
with no injuries thank you
and the vehicle valve is a 2021
genesis it's a mid-sized suv espanola
de la manage hawthorne uh
[Music]
[Music]
so let me switch now to a q a english or
spanish
good afternoon brother sorry did you
explain a little bit more you were
talking about the impairment if there
was no evidence of impairment
can you be more specific about that and
we also made mention that life-saving
efforts were performed
can you be more specific about that well
if the deputies arrive on scene there's
a vehicle that's rolled over there's
someone inside the vehicle they can't
remove them
obviously that's that's we'll leave it
at that he was
he was he was alive and he was he was
conscious
and um that's the extent of that
what about the evidence of the
impairment there was no evidence of
impairment so
subsequent to that we're not going to
make any uh there was no effort to
draw blood for example at the hospital
nothing was removed from the scene or
found at the scene
no evidence of impairment at this point
in time but i'll let you
was tiger woods conscious when you got
there did he say anything
to the paramedics who arrived and could
you tell us a little bit more if we
didn't use the jaws of life
how exactly did that extrication process
take place
okay the information i got back to my
personnel
and the things that they do is they will
do a scene assessment
it was brought to my attention that he
was conscious
now exactly what was said is unknown but
he was
conscious our personnel make an
assessment to
make a determination their level of
consciousness make sure that they're
breathing
uh control any of serious bleeding and
then control
and address any serious injuries it was
brought to my attention that he had
serious leg injuries and that was
assessed at the incident
um the jaws of life are used as far as a
package
to extricate people that are trapped in
vehicles
but it was later determined and brought
to the attention that
the jaws of life were not used to
extricate tiger woods
we used a halogen tube which is a tool
used for prying
and we also used an axe to pry
him from the vehicle he was taken from
the vehicle with
seat a collar backboard for spinal
precautions
he was had the proper splints because of
the nature of the incident being a solar
vehicle
rollover and the fact that it required
an extrication
that met trauma's center criteria the
nearest trauma center to the area's
harbor ucla hospital where he was
transported
serious for stable condition which leg
that i do not know it was my
understanding that it uh serious
injuries to both legs
this was his decision to go to harvard
ucla or you took him to the closest
emergency room
given his condition at the time was it
that severe that's what you had to do
the was the determination of where to be
transported was made by the paramedics
in the cabin
unseen the reason that tiger was
transported to harvard harbor ucla
hospital
is because it's a trauma center criteria
because of the nature of the incident
it was a solo roller vehicle and the
damage to the vehicle
and then it also uh required him to be
extricated
that's one of the criteria that meets
trauma's inner criteria
therefore he was transported to the
nearest trauma center which is
harvard ucla hospital is he airlifted
and can you tell us if he had injuries
anywhere
it was he was not airlifted there were
no other life life
endangering injuries to my knowledge
well surely that question if you would
i know it's a little early
any indication of the speed at the time
that the vehicle
any indication how fast they have been
going
at the time they well the time it made
it crossed the center divider to the
point that it rested with several
several hundred feet away so obviously
that indicates they were going
at a relatively a greater speed than
normal however because it is downhill it
slopes and it also
it curves that area has a high frequency
of
of accidents is not uncommon
no no skid marks no braking so
apparently the first contact was with
the center median
and from there then crossed into the
opposing lane of traffic
hit the curb hit a tree and there was
several
uh rollovers during that process
that they're gonna have to figure that
one out uh that's why the traffic
investors make the big bucks that they
make
uh we've reached out we've been in touch
with it with his manager
and they didn't want to release anything
on his condition we hear that he's out
of surgery
and perhaps been moved to his own room
all we know that a serious condition
as a result of the accident and that's
about all they want to say
that weather is a factor in this
accident weather is not a factor
out of the car how long was that process
well we arrived on scene at 7
18 they were notified within four
minutes and
uh we got the call from the sheriff's
department at approximately
7 22 this morning our resources arrived
on scene
at approximately 7 28 i don't have the
information right now in relation to how
long
it took to extricate him from the
vehicle do you have any indications
or medications involved
no just called it in did someone call
911
no evidence of impairment this time
they'll be subject to the investigation
what exactly what impairments are you
looking for well we're looking at uh
signs of uh
influence under the influence of either
a narcotics medication
alcohol odor of alcohol all these
different things that would give you an
idea and their behavior but there was
not none present
that now we're going beyond what we have
at the time so that'll take
the investigators we'll have to figure
that one out i
a black box understand reports their
information about how fast the car is
going did airbags deployed
through that sort of thing did this
vehicle have that will you get
information from that
the investigators will be able to if
they have it they'll be able to have
that and download it and that will give
us a good idea
well we got the call at 7 12 and that
came from the neighbors so we have to
assume it
they made that call almost immediately
as soon as it happened because
the neighbors are sitting right within
50
feet of the location so they saw
they didn't see it they heard it because
it literally happened right at the
doorstep this is a courtesy car that he
was driving a genesis courtesy car
correct that's correct and is it
possible that mr woods was on the phone
when this accident occurred or is this
one of the factors that we're going to
be considering
that's something we'll we'll have to
explore the investigators will have to
ascertain that if it was a distracted
dark driving
can you describe how the acts of the
special were used
for the vehicle i mean as far as the
doors go i mean how was the tool
as it pertains to the vehicle as
articulated earlier it was a rollover
accident
and so tiger was was trapped inside the
vehicle
so our firefighters and our firefighter
paramedics used
the pry bar they call it hell of the
tube
and it acts to pry parts of the vehicle
away
from him so they were able to safely
extricate him from the vehicle
at what point did he realize he was
tired was he identifying himself and
they kept his license
how did you know who was they recognized
him and he
identified himself as well
from tiger no we don't have that
capability nor do we want it
but the accident crime scene has taken a
long time it's been
it's been there now for several hours
just moving the car now
is there a reason so much time has been
taken at this crime scene
are there certain factors you're looking
at are there certain pieces of evidence
you're hoping to find
or is it simply the fact that this is
tiger woods and this is the way we're
going to handle it well any serious
accident of
this nature is going to take time it
usually takes hours
and removing the vehicle is one of the
last steps and they've
done all their markers took you know
their measurements gathered up all the
stuff and then
three or four hours is pretty normal
actually the celebrity component is not
playing a factor i don't think that'll
play a factor
like checking on his well-being did they
like make it to the site and
actually make contact with them no they
did not
now there's a bluff they're sitting
about 20 feet above
the place where the beagle came to rest
could you talk a little bit about it he
was able to stand
after he was taken out was he able to
take a couple of steps can you talk a
little bit about
what that looked like uh
he was not able to get up now that's not
an option
tiger woods asked you to contact anyone
for him did he ask you to contact a
specific member of his family or a
specific member of his team that was
here but at this point
at the hospital he did but not at the
scene i'm sorry sir
you clarified he did at the hospital but
not at the scene he asked you to contact
yes a member of his family who was it
a member of his team
can you talk about the conditions
well the interior the cabinet of the
vehicle was more or less intact the
front end was totally destroyed the
bumpers everything was destroyed
airbags deployed all of that and uh
however
thankfully the interior was more or less
intact which kind of gave him
the cushion to survive what's otherwise
would have been a fatal crash
[Music]
well he was definitely heading
northbound on hawthorne
uh that he actually struck the first one
going northbound and that was on the
center median
that was the first thing that made
contact with i know you said he was
clearly
three more questions
well like every accident in that area
when it's downhill on a curve
um you know the speed the vehicle code
22 350 says
unsafe speed for driving conditions
typically at an accident when there's
it's a factor that is one of the
sections that decided
and sometimes just because that supposed
speed limit
if there's a wet road for example that
doesn't mean your speed limit is fixed
there you actually have to slow down
even lower than that
for the conditions of the road so
downhill on a curve
is something that it's a lesson for
everyone you got to be aware of this
and then if you could can you just kind
of paint the picture for us again
because i know you'd answer the question
but this is some clarity he's coming
down
off of the hill speed we think is a
factor
what's the first thing he hits when he
loses control and goes over the vehicle
walk us through the sequence of events
there i understand the first thing was
when he made contact with the center
media and it would be the welcome to
rolling hillside
and that's in the center media there's
actually two signs he hit the first one
the southernmost of the two signs
and then he winds up going across
southbound lanes
into the brush on the other side and he
hit the tree is that correct
yes there's a tree about eight inch
stump and that one was sheared
sure you talked about the fact that he
was he communicated to you
can you can you describe to us his pain
threshold this time at the time this is
a man who has to be rushed into surgery
today
and his legs are damaged was was he in
shock was he in tears was he in
excruciating pain
how can you describe his reaction to
those who first go
i would leave that up to sheep austria
[Laughter]
once again daryl was the first boss of
i can't respond to the specifics of
tiger woods i mean some of those uh
questions are personal or need to be
released from him or whoever's
representing him
the only thing i can tell you from my
experience of working
in public safety for the past almost
four decades
that anytime you're involved in a single
deal
vehicle accident like this with rollover
and that level of damage
and broken legs and lacerations that
you're going to be
in severe pain what was your concern
then chief when
he was injured and you're transporting
him how concerned were those paramedics
to get him to the hospital
in a certain amount of time the fact of
the matter is that
he was a serious condition but he was
stable enough to transport
to a trauma center if the injuries were
are more dramatic
and they couldn't control an airway then
they would have transported him
to the nearest facility but the fact
that he was able to stable enough to
be transported to a hospital farther
away which was the most appropriate
hospital to be
transported for because of the nature of
the injuries
the nature of the incident says that it
was a very serious injury
he met a trauma center criteria
but he wasn't so serious that he needed
to be transferred to the nearest
hospital
for immediate life-saving saving
procedures
there's an l.a county uh fire captain
who says
that he was able to stand as they
assisted him out of the vehicle
is there any truth to this idea that he
was able to stay
i cannot respond to that yet i don't
know i will um
it's my understanding that he's still at
the uh harbor journal excuse me harvard
you selling hospital
and um no statement has been allowed for
release yeah
actually before uh deputy gonzalez was
actually the first deputy on scene so he
can
perhaps clarify some of the questions
that you may have
good afternoon i'm deputy gonzalez
assigned to amita sheriff station on the
handling
deputy carlos gonzalez i was the first
unit on scene and i'm the handling
deputy for the uh for this current
traffic collision
deputy gonzalez could you speak to that
question um
there's an elliot county fire captain
who said that uh able to stand
as they assisted him out of the vehicle
there any truth to the idea
that he was able to stand unfortunately
mr woods was not able to stand under his
own power
um our partners at l.a county fire were
able to uh
extricate him from the vehicle and they
put him onto a backboard
when i arrived on scene mr woods was
seen in the driver's seat
i made contact with him and i ensured
that he was
able to speak to me at that time he
seemed that as though he was still calm
and lucid uh i made the determination
that would be safer to wait for heli
county fire to help remove him instead
of trying to remove him myself
i kept mr woods calm until uh l.a county
fire right on scene
what did you do to keep up calm deputy
uh i spoke to him
you know i asked conversation can you
share it with us please i asked him what
his name was
he told me his name was tiger at that
moment i immediately recognized him
i asked him if he knew where he was what
time of day just to make sure he was
oriented
um he seemed as though he was lucid and
uh at home
was he concerned about his injuries
he didn't seem concerned of his injuries
at the time um
which is not uncommon in traffic
collisions many times people tend to be
in shock
it's a traumatic experience so it's not
uncommon for people to be focused on
unimportant things
or even if they are in pain they might
not feel it until much later
so was the incident caught on your body
cam uh yes my body camera was used
for
i did observe injuries i can't speak
into as to the nature of the injuries
i'm not a trained medical professional
so i i can't speak to that
um what i can say is that um he was
injured and
um he was successfully removed and taken
to the hospital
he was wearing a seatbelt did he have
lacerations as well as the
leg if he did i was not able to see them
do it it was clothing you've seen a lot
of car accidents do you think this type
of car saved his life or you think like
a cheaper car
as mentioned by the sheriff that
specific stretch of roadway is one of
our our trouble spots our locals in
ranchopolis verdicts and rolling hills
of states
know that it's a hot spot for traffic
collisions as well as speed
um in my experience as a deputy who is
traffic trained and work
a traffic car i have seen many
collisions the
the nature of his vehicle the fact that
he was wearing a seat belt um i i would
say that it
greatly increased the likelihood that it
saved his life
is this the worst accident you've seen
on that stretch
i will say no because i've been doing
this for a while and i've seen fatal
traffic collisions
so um i will say that it's very
fortunate that mr woods um
was able to uh come out of his life
stretch correct we've seen a number of
accidents on the specific stretch
is that correct this stretch of roadway
is downhill it's sweeping
um speeds there the speed limit is 45
miles per hour
um myself when i'm doing speed
enforcement i will sometimes catch
people going 80 plus miles per hour
so it's more of a thing that this you
know people
uh see a nice stretch of road and maybe
they're not watching their speedometer
or um
you know maybe they they're they're in a
hurry when your conversations with tiger
were you ever concerned
in the time that you spent with him that
of his pain threshold or that he was
going to lose consciousness at all
at the moment that i spoke to mr woods
i was able to determine that it would
have been safer for me to wait for l.a
county fire because his condition seemed
stable and i did not want to risk
further injuring him by trying to remove
myself floating around about like a
bystander who went in
can you tell if there's any so uh the
neighbor that lives behind
heard the collision and came down and
was the one that directed me to the
vehicle
um as was indicated by the sheriff there
was another unrelated traffic collision
that occurred
several feet down the roadway which i
believe was due to people um
trying to look um and that also kind of
distracted from
um what was occurring because he was
several feet off the roadway so i think
most of the attention that people were
focused on was on the road
one more question one more question
uh as indicated by the sheriff uh the
interior passenger compartment of the
vehicle was intact um the airbags didn't
deploy successfully
um again he was wearing his seat belt um
i i think this uh this also kind of
speaks to the uh
the marvel of modern automobiles and
that they're much safer than they've
ever been
previously any idea how many times the
vehicle flipped
well we don't know that this time
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
is
is
uh
um
[Music]
thank you all for coming this concludes
our press conference
we're going now
i need a mic yeah
thank you guys
you